sickle cell anemia is an inherited blood
disease that affects your red blood
cells it's one of the most common and
usually most severe forms of a group of
red blood cell disorders called sickle
cell disease in order to survive your
body needs red blood cells to supply
oxygen to its tissues
red blood cells are made inside the
center of your bones called bone marrow
there immature cells called blood stem
cells can divide to make all types of
blood cells including red blood cells
normal red blood cells are disc shaped
each of them contains protein molecules
called hemoglobin that carry oxygen
round flexible red blood cells flow
easily through your bloodstream and pick
up oxygen in your lungs
in tiny air sacs in the lungs called
alveoli oxygen moves into the blood and
attaches to the hemoglobin in red blood
cells
then the red blood cells deliver oxygen
to cells throughout the body
in sickle cell anemia there is a problem
with your hemoglobin that makes your red
blood cells sickle shaped instead of
round this is caused by a defective Gene
that is passed from both parents to
children through genetic material in
your cells called DNA DNA is made up of
sections called genes
two of the genes called alphaglobin and
beta globin contain the blueprints for
making the hemoglobin proteins
in sickle cell anemia the beta globin
Gene has changed or mutated
this mutation leads to the formation of
an abnormal hemoglobin protein called
hemoglobin s
hemoglobin s forms into rigid strands
inside your red blood cells
which causes the red blood cell to be
sickle shaped
Sickle cells can block blood flow and
can cause pain and tissue damage
and while normal red blood cells last 90
to 120 days Sickle cells only last 10 to
20 days
your body may not be able to keep up
with how fast the cells are destroyed as
a result your blood has less red blood
cells than normal
this condition is called anemia the
symptoms of sickle cell anemia vary from
person to person but may include
episodes of pain in your body parts such
as your hands and feet lower back chest
and abdomen a yellow tint in the whites
of the eyes and skin called jaundice
and feeling tired due to anemia
over time sickle cell anemia can lead to
complications such as severe pain
and damage to your eyes heart
lungs liver kidneys
and Joints damage to your spleen an
organ that makes immune cells can
increase your risk of infections
the risk for sickle cell anemia is
highest among people with ancestors from
sub-Saharan Africa
Hispanic areas of South America the
Caribbean and Central America
Saudi Arabia
India
and Mediterranean countries
to find out more about sickle cell
anemia talk to your health care provider